signori miei oggi proviamo due giochi
non uno ben due perché sembra qualità il
chelsea dove proviene due il primo è
basse stop blast come possiamo vedere
dalla qualità del dl giochiamo pick up
del control chissenefrega drive per
camera luksic stack bus e una di questa
perché perché l'hanno fatta a mano pick
up del 7 a monte of kings deve ok prendi
i ragazzi e portali a scuola prima che
il tempo finisca va bene questo e non ho
fatto in tempo a leggere quindi posso
andare via
che bello e veramente un mezzo stabile
questo mi piace tantissimo
devo andare a prendere i ragazzi è
bellissimo che c'è la video camera in
basso a sinistra mi piace un sacco
questi sono i bambini
ciao ma gli o investiti oddio distrutto
la casa giovanni atp entrano loro se ti
fermi va bene let's go
ma chi a quelle rho schaeuble e
giustamente alla scuola amici né oggi né
uccisi due bebè che io devo portare più
bambini a scuola possibili
questa è una fattoria era una fattoria
ucciso un po di mucche permesso dispiace
è volato la mucca fino qua è una palla
di mucca non è una mucca però va bene
bambini tutti sopra tutti sopra che si
va a scuola veloci ma ti possibile o 21
me interessa dove vi farà prendere tutti
in teoria a meno che non mi faccia fare
altri giri porca vacca c'è veramente tu
come fai devi raccoglierli tutti per
forza 19 posti 37 come non ce la faccio
potrebbe anche darsi che ce la faccia ma
non è detto di andare lì e tornano a
scuola in 30 secondi ai provaci veloci
che quanto tempo frena eccoli i miei
ragazzi perfetto ciglio tutti
sono un miliardo di posti giusto auto
sua bene i ragazzi rimanenti 28 com'è
possibile
due sono gli ho calcolato il tempo
preciso per arrivare a scuola
secondo mancamento impossibile perfetto
4.000 dollari miglia competiamo list i
bambini ragazzi mancati 1200 ma
dov'erano
vabbè profitto 4.800 a sberle a farlo
youtube next round ho capito cosa farò
dopo youtube compagni bambini a col
tasto the fuck ha perso un vagone
bambini entrate che devo fare i soldi
veloci bene per oggi i soldi per fare è
fatto meglio il riquadro in basso a
sinistra che il gioco
il quadro è basso sinistra bellissimo
cioè gli effetti ha persino l'ombra
sfumata dell'autobus
il gioco no il gioco normale non ce l'ha
va bene qualche qualità nel basso city e
potrete guardare solo anche solo lì
molto bene entrate veloci ha impennato
sbaglio cosa sto vedendo con quale
fisica quindi se vai a tutta velocità e
poi tiri il freno
l'autobus impenna mi sembra ovvio io che
ho studiato fisica avevo sempre 10 in
fisica e normalissima questa cosa
9 maschile dove come kid left 29 per
questa è l'ultima causa in teoria non ci
se non siano nascosti in giro tutti giù
tutti velocemente a scuola che già mi
state scassando le balle che la metà
basta ben 3.500 possiamo vedere un video
un'occhiata in giro perché non ho ben
capito dove dove dovrebbero essere gli
altri bambini però si stacca coltivano a
staccarsi in vagoni dell'autobus ma non
fa niente
bono ha forse quelli che investono li
prende io pensavo che entrassero quelli
che investivi giustamente così che
investi non entrano nell'autobus va bene
sono io scemo l'avevo capito dai quindi
bisogna affiancarli e star fermi chiaro
chiaro grad e molto bene qua c o meno
posti in realtà però che
demoni o c o meno posti perché l'autobus
si è mischiato un po quindi non possono
entrare tutti stavolta porca vacca
quanti sono entrate veloci non c'è più
posto devo consegnarvi tipo amazon via
via via via via via via via via lo
proveranno ce la farò mai però ci provo
venti secondi dai dai dai veloce investì
la mucca sbattitene molto bene entrate
di in b stupidi che vi istruisco io
veloci 10 secondi vai io ero mai mai mai
mai nella vita
5 entro in aula direttamente non ci
credo ora poiché sono entrati al cav h
beh dai non è male volta sono andato
abbastanza bene f faccio schifo comunque
va bè next round manca l'ultimo e poi ho
finito di teoria tanto non avevano fatto
che bello il gas che esce dal tubo di
scarico da entrate solo un po perché poi
non posso prendere tutti a fare un giro
incredibile dopo prendete annuncia farò
mai pro kay
a meno che non sfondo le case ma non
penso uscite veloci e che drifting devo
fare un giro abnorme per riuscire a
prenderli tutti forse c'è la forza e già
faccio uno è amalgamato la alla panchina
perfetto vai muri bueno mancano gli
ultimi che non so se ce la faccio io qui
mi devo fiondare con un maledetto ahi
ahi porca forse ce la faccio no qua il
massimo perfetto boss fu il non c'è più
nessuno
non solo consegnarli devo sfondare tutto
a scuola veloci imparate a perfetto viva
l'istruzione dance for plein in prego
prego
e come f come f raga non è possibile c'è
come fece presi tutti vabbè un gioco
memorabile grazie di averci regalato del
tempo c'è diverso tolto herat ha però fa
niente fosse viva c'è il secondo
capolavoro di oggi spero sia un po
meglio dal titolo mi sembrava più
intelligente di quello che abbiamo
appena fatto dei confratelli key of
trust la confraternita dei toast
galleria d'arte molto bella ha prezzo
extra oneroso game per sé tua inter va
bene c'è un over basse supermarket 50
per cento di sconto sui tosto era
l'autobus questo tosto blasfemo
non abbiamo prezzo va bene devo andare a
comprare dei toast cimitero è successo
qua post i toast morti non ci credo c'è
una pala to come io l'ho scavar mela da
solo la tomba no confraternite of the
host a sinistra e non posso entrare qua
a si suona permesso ai chiuso
va bene c'è un toast a forma di culo ma
è la religione questa che non ho capito
salve state pregando prega la
confraternita ma è un culo c'è un posto
un po più ok a questa era il bus di
prima che se un po schiantato la vecchia
parte no amico mio
ce la farò ti salverà la vita e quello
non è che ciampi immagine poi tanto sta
morendo ora che faccia agonizzante che a
fantastiche bello che questo video per
queste parole non sarà family friendly
eppure lo è tantissimo stessa cosa fai
uccidere tutti gli umani ma perché ma
amico mio cosa cioè contro gli umani
mica vi mangia cioè va beh in realtà sì
però premesso questo sta giocando al
computer quanto largo skopje mi piace
programmare si vede se sei un po come i
programmatori questo gioco l'espressione
penso sia quella qualcuno mi spiega dove
si pregano i toast da qualche parte ma
posso fare qualcosa di suo gioco vado in
giro solo vedere i toast che pregano
io vorrei salvare questo mio amico però
si è schiantato e non posso farci niente
posso salieri qua ok ma c'è una porta
una porta segreta per accedere alla
confraternita
ciao dovrebbero togliere la licenza ai
programmatori quando si fanno di canne
questo è questa è una regola che io ho
sempre pensato comunque ben intravedo
già della qualità video ludica dopo
quella porta salve signor e del dio del
tosto immagino si no questa è la
risposta cosa mi rappresenta sta roba
salve vi dica vuoi entrare nella
confraternita si o no devo entrare nella
porta in base alla mia scelta
questa sì o no se io metto no che
succede così trasforma in un horror tipo
slider me con i toast che ti seguono
vogliono uscire attenzione c'è una linea
rossa non devo sorpassarla a ok questa
non me lo aspettavo sinceramente little
john sono divertente sono divertente sì
sei molto divertente dove sto andando
spero che tu capisca l'importanza del
mai contraddire il nostro superiore ma
nel rock mi aveva fatto una domanda
saremo una famiglia al grande e bella
unisciti alla confraternita a devo
mettere sì per forza va bene voglio
entrare nella confraternita di mia
spontanea volontà wellcomm va bene se ci
si sono anche impegnati per fare questa
cosa è quello che fa ridere se sto gioco
lo programma un bambino ogni due anni lo
fa meglio però tranne le macchine per le
sono fatte benissimo piuttosto sono
molto più voluti di noi a quanto vedo ci
sono le macchine volanti fantastico
premesso
sono dentro mi sono fatto di hashish
probabilmente questo l'effetto prova
labirinto test 1 la tua madre morta ma
come sottratta all inizio ma sono due
ore che cammino ma cosa cosa che senso
spero vi sia piaciuto
mamma mia che tragedia di jo ma cos'è
però che vi sia piaciuto ottimo
labirinto buttato la mia vita lì adesso
c'è una famiglia non me ne sono neanche
accorto ma ok però i vi sia piaciuto
cose tanto mi piace anche per i social
condito da descrizione se non sapere se
rischiate noi ci vediamo dopo seguito
senza toast e per ripicca stasera mi
mangio 26 da ragazzi
[Musica]